Siri called June Mom this is FaceTime oh
gosh I need you to write a couple of
things down the car keys I just said
write it down you're not writing it down
Kevin and I are headed to LAX and we
need you to pick us up on Monday keep
your location on the entire time I'm
away no fun got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys
my mom never came home from her trip I
don't know where she is I'm calling
about a guest you had
um does anyone speak English I'm sorry
salvation Park please I need your help
the FBI doesn't have jurisdiction to
investigate in Colombia so is there
anything I can do the best thing you can
do to help us is just wait by your phone
I'm not giving up on my mom
go to this hotel and ask for their
security footage
says she sees two American tourists
what did he buy just this do you think
he did something to her
you're going through Kevin's email you
need to let the police handle this I
tried but we're running out of time who
are these
this woman calls him Darren
hey we're gonna tell me my mom was
dating a felon you need to trust me on
this shocking new footage has leaked
online
I have some questions regarding
something we're looking into has your
mom ever gone by any other names
what the strangest case I've ever seen
there may be more than meets the eyes
there are some legit questions
okay June bug there's actually a lot I
want to talk with you about
God
yeah